all right guys bang-bang I'm super
excited to have Alex class team back
thank you so much for doing this man
yeah it's been close to a year and a
half since I was on last and it feels
like we're in a new age for sure let's
start just for those that didn't listen
to the first episode maybe just give a
quick one-minute on your background and
then what the human rights foundations
focus is absolutely so again my name is
Alex Gladstein I'm the chief strategy
officer of the Human Rights Foundation
which is a non-profit based in New York
City which focuses on challenging
authoritarianism around the world and on
helping people who live under
authoritarian regimes so we do a lot of
civil liberties work a lot of free
expression work we help journalists who
are at risk we help democracy movements
around the world using peaceful tactics
using new technology by building
networks and expanding people's
horizontal ties to one another I've been
doing this since 2007 my work has taken
me around the world
I've worked extensively with Cuban
dissidents with the Cuban underground
Library movement is where I got started
at HRF basically helping my Latin
American colleagues who could travel to
Cuba smuggle in kind of forbidden films
and books that like people would read
and watch inside their homes in Cuba and
this later turned into what is now I
kept a the system were some Cubans have
a satellite receiver and they like
basically download a bunch of Spanish
Netflix type stuff and then distribute
it out in their communities but before
that existed
Cubans relied on organizations like us
to like get flash drives and hard drives
of content that was forbidden to watch
Cuba's a communist country in the
government you know doesn't allow you to
watch read anything that they don't
approve of so that was kind of I cut my
teeth on that kind of experience which
taught me that information is power and
it could be incredibly powerful to
change society and then I spent a lot of
time in the sort of 2009 to 1213 era
working on North Korea traveling to
South Korea very often meeting North
Korean defectors and refugees and try
to get an understanding of how we could
help them and what they told us is that
we need more help
sending information into North Korea so
again we looked at that and started
doing balloon air drops of flash drives
and USB keys and DVDs into North Korea
we started supporting the these kind of
underground networks that sell foreign
media and information into North Korea
so I spent a lot of time doing that
more recently over the last four years
I've developed a strong interest in
financial freedom and privacy and I came
on the show most notably you know to
discuss the idea that that bitcoin is
freedom in many ways and we talked at
length about why I think Bitcoin matters
so much for human rights especially for
the four plus billion people around the
world who are cut off from the financial
system who don't have the luxuries and
conveniences that you or I might have
and whose governments are much more
abusive and reckless than the ones were
even looking at today and who have much
more to fear from surveillance than than
we might I mean we're worried Amane Lee
about surveillance capitalism and you
know overreach of marketing many many
cases for most people in the West but
these folks are afraid of getting
basically bagged it's and and you know
secretly carried away to some gulag in
many of these countries and that the
human rights foundation we focus on the
93 or so countries that we consider
authoritarian know they don't have a
Free Press they don't have an
independent judiciary you can't sue the
government you can't create an NGO so
they have a very special need set and
you know my work at HRF is built on how
can we help them so me personally I work
a lot on the fundraising side the growth
side marketing side and again have
developed this massive interest in you
know the world Bitcoin can play in the
global struggle for human human rights
for sure so I wanted to record another
episode mainly because the Cova 19 biros
has created a health scare and that
health crisis is now driving an economic
crisis and I think there's a lot of
people who are very nervous
right now because they say whenever you
have a health crisis and an economic
crisis like this the will of free people
gets tested meaning that they're much
more open to receiving quote-unquote
help or having government's implement
temporary measures or more surveillance
or things that maybe wouldn't be as easy
to get across the finish line during a
time when there wasn't those health and
economic crises and so maybe let's just
start with like what how bad the problem
really is right I know that you guys
have done some work on understanding we
see data being presented from countries
all around the world around the health
crisis and economic crisis but just if
it is an authoritarian country like how
much can we believe the data that we're
getting and how do you guys think about
kind of level setting those data sets
versus countries where maybe there's
more democracy or transparency and
confirmation of the numbers and data I'm
really glad you asked us and I want to
unpack it with you and with everybody
who's listening because I think there's
a lot of lessons to draw here first of
all I think we're being led to believe
in many cases especially even in open
societies Western countries that there's
a lot of lessons in authoritarianism
and that we should grant emergency
powers to our rulers in times of crisis
and that like a very strong centralized
kind of response is probably best and
that maybe we even want to grant
extraordinary surveillance powers and
that there's a lot to learn from China
and the Chinese government and I think
this is the very long and dangerous
perspective to take I think that there's
this sort of cultural war that's
starting to happen to bubble over where
it's arguably not even so much a war as
a battle that's almost being almost won
by a particular side and that's again
the side of you know the public safety
is more important than civil liberties
and again these are arguments coming
from mainstream people the mainstream
media and a lot of technologists
actually who are like well whatever
privacy who cares what's more important
now is that we save lives and then and
they kind of look to China and China's
quote unquote performance as validation
of their argument and what you're
starting to see is people become very
less a fair about about their rights and
freedoms because they they're just
focused on what the what they're
learning about kovat and and how
potentially these governments can
protect them what's very very important
to understand is that the performance of
authoritarian governments is not what it
seems
so you might look at the data now that
the Financial Times or New York Times is
reporting you constantly see these
little charts that the Financial Times
puts out of cases and deaths in it it
shows all these countries kind of like
going up over time and then it shows
China with this like amazing flattening
of the curve and now it looks like
things are cool they're now and the
Financial Times as one of the papers of
record of them in the world to be honest
kind of repeats this day daily over and
over and over again they're hitting
people over the head with the idea that
China has solved the problem and the
problem the core problem is the core
issue is the Financial Times is
regurgitating data from the Chinese
Communist Party they're regurgitating
lies the Chinese Communist Party
remember has been lying for the last
half decade to the world about the
prison camps in gulags and Xinjiang in
the northwest part of China in the
northwest part of China we can see from
outer space using satellite imagery that
there are vast numbers a huge network of
concentration camps prison camps where
the CCP the Chinese Communist Party is
imprisoning male Weaver's they are a
Muslim minority ethnic minority and they
are imprisoning according to the latest
estimates we have anywhere from 1 to 2
million people in these camps and this
is such a shocking thing such a visible
thing see it from outer space and yet
they lie and and deny that they exist so
we're going to take this regime's word
that there's whatever it is 4,000 deaths
is what they're reporting and all the
mainstream media and all of our
policymakers and all of these
influencers in Silicon Valley are
basically looking at China and saying
yeah we might have to you know follow
some of their measures they've you know
I know you know they're like well you
know they might be doing some things we
don't like but you know you can't deny
the the results and I'm telling you you
need to deny the results those results
are fake
there are extensive reports in Hebei
province where Wuhan is where the
epicenter of the outbreak originally
started where people have just been
watching the funeral homes and they've
just been looking at the urns that are
coming in and out and this was back like
a month ago but basically local
residents estimated that there had to be
at least 40,000 deaths based on just
what they saw in that one city alone
okay I would be shocked if the actual
number of Cova deaths in China was less
than a quarter million I'd shocked and
yet the news media you know and I say
that in a in a kind of half loving way I
mean Free Press is really important but
people have become so gullible in
believing what China is saying that
we're kind of getting sucked into this
mindset that we should be more like that
like there's so many arguments and
articles written by influencers in
Britain in the United States saying
there's a lot to learn from China and
I'm telling you yes there is a lot to
learn from China we should run as far
away from their government model as
possible and the final piece to this
puzzle is that if it is true that we
should seek a more authoritarian
structure in our societies so that we
can handle public health crises more
effectively let's just give them the
benefit of doubt and say that that's
that's their honest argument then we
need to consider the fact that how is it
possible that the one of the most
authoritarian governments from the world
one of the most secretive governments in
the world the government that has the
most censorship and surveillance per
capita of any Society in human history
did such a bad job controlling the help
break at the beginning in December and
in January
that you know even with all their
Orwellian surveillance Tech and all the
control they had and all of this strong
centralization under Xi Jinping they
failed the virus became an outbreak and
has killed untold numbers of Chinese and
devastated their economy and you know
has basically ruined the their their
global brand so if they couldn't stop
this thing with all the centralized
control and surveillance in the world
then I think the lessons that we need to
draw are that we need to take a
different approach we need to fight this
particular crisis kovat other public
health crises and any sort of national
disaster whether it be from another
nation state or from a natural
perspective economic perspective we need
to fight these things with a spirit of
openness and innovation and a free flow
of information if we allow the kind of
axes of censorship and control and
surveillance to win the day we're not
gonna like the results and so I guess
part of this is there was an outbreak
people got sick that then spread across
the entire world and there's kind of two
separate bodies of work here in my
opinion one is analyzing what's already
happened right and understanding you
know both to prevent it from happening
again but also to try to inform the
second body of work which is what do we
do now part of that first body of work
is as we go to understand what's already
occurred there's a bunch of talk around
using various types of content contact
tracking or surveillance mechanisms in
order to understand who's been infected
who's been where who's come in contact
with somebody who's infected now all of
these different approaches so maybe we
can dive into what exactly is contact
trip tracking what are some of the
things people have proposed and then
where is the line
between trying to understand what's
already occurred and also protecting the
civil liberties and personal freedoms
that people should come to know and
expect especially in democratic
countries yeah well before we get too
deep into contact tracing let's just
define some terms and and I'd like to
just clarify my own position on how
seriously I'm taking kovat I mean I I
shared a Venn diagram with some of my
followers recently that I saw that I
really liked in it it kind of had three
circles which overlapped in the middle
and one was that I think kovat is very
dangerous it needs to be take very very
seriously one is that the economic
devastation that will happen as a result
of government response to covet is
dangerous and needs to be taken very
seriously and one is that the
authoritarian overreach from governments
with regard to civil liberties and
surveillance is very dangerous it needs
to be taken seriously
you can believe all three of these
things this is there's no like conflict
in that so that's kind of where I'm
coming from and I'm looking at this from
the perspective of who's who's actually
handling the virus the best from a
perspective of statistics and data like
who's actually doing the best with
regard to number of deaths number of
cases etc and the reality is that some
of the best countries in performance
pure performance are democracies we can
look at countries like Taiwan South
Korea etc there look there are even
parts of the United States there are
large country sized states you know the
United States that have very few deaths
you know so there are certain countries
like Portugal like New Zealand like
Iceland that are doing really well and
these are all these are all countries
that have chosen to fight this thing in
a more open way and what are the tools
they're using
so let's actually break that down so if
you look at each kind of thing that we
as a society can do to fight epidemics
let's say let's say virally spreading
epidemics hand-washing is number one
step and that that's completely
compatible with civil liberties we
should all wash our hands all the time
okay that's like obvious that does not
take any sort of authoritarian measure
to impose masks see masks are very
important if you actually look at a
country like Hong Kong I got the
pleasure of interviewing Joshua Wong
who's like probably the most famous Hong
Kong protester recently and you know he
told me I asked him Joshua how is it
possible that Hong Kong can only have
seven deaths seven this is a similar
size to metropolitan area in New York
City which has you know twenty-five plus
thousand deaths
how does Hong Kong have seven and you
know is that because of Kerry lamb and
the Hong Kong government are they doing
a great job and he said no no no the
Hong Kong citizenry had a decentralized
response we understood the risks because
of SARS and the data says 98% of Hong
Kongers wear masks and have been wearing
masks since January and 80% of them
stayed home as much as possible that's
why there's only seven deaths not
because of authoritarian response from
Kerry lamb so masks are really really
important and bonus for folks here who
like freedom and privacy masks help you
obviously against the facial recognition
in the surround state so we like masks
here testing I mean testing is so
critically important massive amounts of
testing it should be super easy to go
get a test
finally it's becoming easier in
California to do that but it's been
really frustrating to watch the last six
weeks of failure by officials federal
and local just not getting tests but
societies that can do massive amounts of
testing obviously can more quickly
separate those who are sick from those
who are not and get us back to work I
think that social distancing is is very
important obviously I mean hopefully not
permanently but for now it's something
that can be recommended you know without
an undue imposition on our civil
liberties and then you have you know the
you know a couple a couple a couple
other things but when it comes to
contact tracing
you know what contact tracing is really
important contact tracing is something
that's not done with technology contact
tracing as a term is a medical operation
that's that's done by health officials
where they sit you down and once they
realize you're sick and they interview
you and they figure out where you've
been and they ask you you've come into
contact with and then they call those
people and Warren
right that's actually really really
important and we need to do a lot of
that where I have a prop what the the
tactic that I have a problem it is
digital contact tracing this idea that
we can automate the process by using our
cell phones and the location data of our
cell phones to figure out who's come
into contact with who and from what I've
seen there is no evidence to suggest
that this works all other things being
equal
meaning if you look at a country like
Taiwan or South Korea and you look at
their track record and you look at how
well they've performed there is no clear
indication that it is because of this
mass surveillance that they're doing
well it is much much much more likely
that it is because citizens are wearing
masks and social distancing and they've
shut down certain businesses and you
know have certain measures to prevent
people from gathering that is why they
are doing as well not because of contact
tracing the Health Minister essentially
if Taiwan was interviewed recently and
he basically said that despite the fact
that Taiwan is in my opinion doing some
worrying surveillance even in Taiwan
that they're doing some worrying
surveillance where they're they're using
kind of telecom data they're trying to
look at people's cell phones and figure
out what's happening this has only been
helpful in one case he said on the
record with a journalist one case
Singapore which has been doing a ton of
this stuff and people were pointing to
as a success story has seen a big
outbreak recently so it's not working so
well for them and even in Israel which
was one of the first countries to do
like a very aggressive phone tracking
program the officials have recently come
out in the last few days and says it
hasn't really been helpful okay so we
have some data from quite a few
countries saying that there's no real
evidence that this thing is is a
difference maker and yet when Apple and
Google came out with their announcement
that they were going to collaborate on a
digital contact tracing platform for the
world and remember between them
that's covering three billion people I
think about all the people who have
Android devices Apple devices etc so
we're talking about like a third of the
world could come under surveillance from
this particular idea and people were
cheering dude like people from Silicon
Valley investors media they were all
like this is so great and I'm sitting
here being like this is the culture war
over privacy this is this is my side
losing how is this possible how are
people so short-sighted
that they've forgotten what has what is
Google done in the last decade just to
prove that they care about your privacy
seriously and people look at this if you
if you don't if you looked at the
documentation but it's like very thin
very vague very utopian further for
their plan to basically use the
Bluetooth technology in your phone and
the sort of very brief weight that I'll
kind of summarize the way it works is
that your Bluetooth technology in your
phone when you have an app that uses
Bluetooth running basically can send out
a little signal to other phones in in a
particular radius okay it's not tracking
your exact location it's just kind of
sonar hangout right and it's just kind
of beep-beep and whenever you come into
contact with someone else who also has
this happening your phone and that phone
can exchange like an encrypted number
okay and then like your phone basically
monitors who the other numbers it's come
into contact with and uploads this list
of numbers to a database and then that
database alerts your phone if you've
come into contact with someone who ends
up being positive that's like the way
they've pitched it the problem is that
there are a lot of vulnerabilities in
this system even at the base layer I was
looking at something today that said
that basically the problem comes from
when you did you declare that you're
positive right so when you declare
you're positive all of a sudden like
your identifiers are declared as
positive and companies can start
marketing to you understanding that
you're positive government's obviously
know that you're positive because you
have to declare yourself positive and
there
a lot of vulnerabilities even on that
level but even if we're to assume that
they make it as privacy protecting as
possible this Apple Google
infrastructure they're not building the
app they're just building the protocol
so governments and companies are gonna
build the apps folks
so just remember Apple and Google aren't
building the app they're building a
protocol for phones to talk to each
other and that might be
privacy-preserving I still think there's
monitor abilities Moxie Marlinspike the
creator of signal has a really good
thread on this that you can look at I
still think there's possibilities for
issues even on the base layer but we
have to remember that governments and
companies are actually gonna make the
app and what they're gonna do is combine
this kind of like very accurate
Bluetooth tracking technology Bluetooth
tracking technology can can can be
accurate to the inch
whereas GPS or cell phone tracking
generally speaking is much less accurate
you know it's it's not that accurate I
mean you can't even use it for digital
contact tracing because it's you know
it's not accurate within 10 meters etc
but Bluetooth contact tracing is
accurate to the inch so what we're doing
is in you know societies in the process
of cheering on to companies that are
known privacy violators Google of course
everywhere an Apple in China especially
and we're cheering them on for
implementing a brand new much more
potent location tracking system for
potentially billions of people and it's
just stunning for me to watch this
happen and it's really sad and I think
people haven't thought about the
implications and I can guarantee you
that the actual products that people use
later on top of this platform are gonna
have all kinds of personal data so again
even if we take them at their utopian
noble word that their platform that
Apple and Google are making is gonna be
as privacy-preserving as possible again
they're not making the apps companies
and governments are gonna make the apps
and they're gonna take this incredible
new tech that's being invented
essentially on the spot that's going to
give them the ability to monitor people
based on their Bluetooth interactions
and then they're gonna combine that with
your name your phone number where you've
been etc and they're gonna have a real
time understanding of every single
person that you've come into contact
with and they can't do that right now
the current triangulation of cell phone
tracking doesn't allow them to do that
if you listen to the for example that
the Rogen episode was Snowden he talks
about how your phone has a unique
identifier it has a you've SIM card as
unique identifiers etc and you know
they're tracking you they're looking at
your phone and they're triangulating you
but this is Wayne we're talking
something that's way more accurate so
this like base layer protocol can be
used in combination with your other
personal data to give a government or
company real time understanding of every
single person that you speak to or
encounter on a daily basis and they
didn't have that before and the masses
are cheering for it and that's what I
think people need to think hard about
what are we trading off for this and
does it even work I was so stunned to
see that everybody's so excited about
this as if they think digital contact
tracing even works
there's not even evidence that it works
I mean what's your reaction to that yeah
I mean my whole thing is words really
matter and so if you think about it from
a marketing standpoint if you call it
digital contact tracking all of a sudden
people are much more open to it right
that they're hey we need this youthful
missamma sounds great
you know if I said to you we're going to
surveil the population and then we're
going to label who is positive and who
is not all of a sudden that sounds a lot
more scary a lot more worrisome right
and so the language you know there's a
joke that I always go back to and I've I
had to go back and figure out who it was
it was Chris Rock or who the comedian
was but there's basically they're saying
something to the effect of the greatest
marketing campaign in the world was the
use of the word insurgent so we went
into Iraq and Afghanistan we said hey
we're taking on the insurgents we're
gonna go kill the insurgents and
everyone in the United States looked
around and said well I'm not an
insurgent you
I'm a surgeon I don't know any
insurgents go kill them all kill all the
insurgents but it instead we had said
hey we're gonna go kill people who are
pissed off that we invaded their country
or we're gonna go kill humans
people say well time out I don't want to
kill the humans I thought we were just
gonna kill the insurgents right it's got
a different kind of connotation to it
when you change the language and so I
think that this is another example where
digital contact tracking sounds very
scientific it sounds very kind of health
oriented it sounds like it's something
that we as a society have to do to stop
the virus right this invisible enemy
what how do we do it
we agreed to digital contact tracking
but the static you say no we're gonna
surveil the society and we're gonna
label people to hold from yes so just
when you hear digital contact tracing
just think in your mind citizen
surveillance and I look I was even
surprised to see Snowden and the ACLU
come out and say basically hey we're
watching this carefully but maybe it
could be good I mean it can only be bad
I mean let me explain the slippery slope
if we become more comfortable and if
this normalization of mass surveillance
is made possible through this crisis if
the governments take this crisis and see
an opportunity and say hey here's an
opportunity for us to make mass
surveillance more palatable more
reasonable we can see we can speak again
you know those signs of marketing we can
make it sound slick and call it digital
contact tracing you know where does it
end and I'll tell you where it ends it
ends with something called color coding
citizen color coding so in China in who
Bay Province and elsewhere now that
they're quote-unquote coming out of
lockdown which you know in it of itself
is arguable and and I think a lot of it
is a Potemkin village based on what I
know but let's just assume that
okay so China is is regardless of
whether the virus has been beaten back
or not they are allowing people to start
to like leave their homes etc etc etc so
in order to like leave your home go to
work get on public transportation your
phone needs to display a certain color
green yellow red and if you're red you
can't go anywhere so you need to be
green so who decides
what is green and what is yellow there
was a video I watched which was quite
informative from a British guys living
there now
and you know he's he's he's yellow and
he's sitting in a room with this woman
who's Chinese and she's green and
they're not wearing masks and they're
just like within five feet of each other
talking and you know heard her colors
not going to yellow so like I don't know
how it works but it's it's clearly
probably a little more propaganda than
actual science the point is that you are
gonna be color coded based on how the
government perceives you as a threat to
the operation of society so it's not
like you know it's it's it's not like
the app is capable of actually
understanding if you're but you know in
fact it or not or have a particular
issue or not some human tells the app
you know what what you're doing like and
it gives you a score so this builds into
what we I think touched on on on the
last show about how over the last decade
the Chinese government has been building
this idea of a citizens core which is
kind of like a credit score but it also
adds behavior your friends things like
that into your basically reliability
score and for them it's more like a
patriotism score and your patriotism
score dictates you know what kind of
loan you can get where you can travel
what kind of schools your kids can get
into etc so on top of that
infrastructure which is built out you
know at the municipal level it's built
out at the corporate level there's a lot
of different experiments all around
China each region has a kind of
different one there now adding this like
color coding to the mix so now they're
basically able to control your movements
in China based on like what color you
have and there's a there's a old Soviet
joke that a dress chairman Gary Kasparov
likes to say that nothing is more
permanent than a temporary measure and
you know that could not bring more true
right now it's not like the color coding
is going away and even in the West even
in our countries it's not like the
Google Apple Bluetooth con digital
context racing is going away it's not
like they're gonna in six months delete
it off your phone no they're gonna find
a new reason for it the FBI is gonna
look at and be like hey this is actually
really useful for this other thing that
we need or some other companies gonna
say hey this would be way easier for us
to understand the mark
behavior of our customers we want to
keep it that's coming to stay
every time we like add one of these new
innovations in citizen surveillance and
behavior tracking it doesn't go away it
stays that's one thing that we have
learned and you have to think about this
idea that we are on the slippery slope
to cut to color coding and it's gonna
get more inescapable because our devices
as we've all seen in the last two
decades are shrinking I mean that the
things that we use to communicate with
each other and rely on are going from
computers that that sit on our desks and
we have to like go to two phones that go
in our pocket to wearables that we were
on our wrist to eventually a chip dude
that's gonna be either in your wrist or
your retina or whatever
I'm sure that's gonna happen in the next
twenty thirty years absolutely and you
have to think about this like evolution
of your digital identity and how it's
gonna kind of go from kind of over the
skin surveillance to under the skin
surveillance which is a concept that
you've all know Harare the historian
talks about but I think this all ends in
something that I want to call privacy
shaming I think that's what's gonna
happen as we get further down the road
and you're starting to see it now like
I'm getting shamed on Twitter for
example for basically sounding the alarm
on the digital contact tracing thing and
trying to challenge people on the Apple
and Google project people are calling me
religious fundamentalist a privacy
absolutist whatever I'm getting shamed
and I think like down the road
especially with the young generation I
think what you're gonna see is like it's
gonna be cool to have these like
wearables chips whatever like new
devices and people who are like caring
about privacy and rights and freedoms
will maybe be uncool and I think that's
gonna happen in the future we're very
worried about that and it's something I
kind of keeps me up at night and we can
we can stop it by creating an
alternative narrative that privacy is
cool you know that it's actually cool to
have Rights and Freedoms and it is
essential to the backbone of our society
and the country we've built here in the
USA it's actually cool to protect your
livelihood and the information
about yourself and that's a narrative
that I would want to do my best to help
build yeah I think part of what you're
talking about here so this idea that
technology continues to get closer and
closer to the body right so if you take
just a traditional technology trend
there used to be kind of very large head
so it's kind of like you're wearing
downward they're kind of over the ear
very big people will for remember even
once with like Walkmans or CD players
then we got to the Apple headphone are
kind of the in-ear headphone that still
had a Accord on it right and plugged
into a device now we've got iPods with
Aurra I'm sorry the air pods which will
go in your ear they're wireless the
belief is that at some point we continue
get closer and closer that'll be just
implanted whether so your brain or
somewhere and so technology in general
continues to get smaller more powerful
and kind of closer to being some sort of
embeddable and that may take 10 20 30
years but like that's the general
direction the technology is taking it
would be no surprise then that the
technology that is used for nefarious
things do the same thing right it's not
like the nefarious technology is gonna
fight the trend of getting smaller more
powerful and getting closer to an
embeddable type product and so I guess
you know as you look at this is there a
difference between the chip embedded in
your hand or your retina or something
like that versus what's on the phone and
kind of what they're trying to do now or
is it the same type of surveillance but
just in a different form factor on the
technology side well I mean yeah of
course you could leave your phone at
home if you want to you can put it down
you can do things to your phone to
prevent it from tracking you meaning you
can friend of mine Matt Odell who runs
the the FTC podcast he has a good series
of guides showing you how to take your
like Google phone and basically strip it
of all the Google software and install
something called graphene which is a
very privacy protecting OS and you can
use a tor browser and different apps on
the phone to basically be completely
private it
really really cool but that stuff is is
gonna be limited as we get close as this
technology shrinks and shrinks and
shrinks and becomes more proprietary
less open source and eventually comes in
to you so I think it's important that we
like fight now to make sure that the
open source Pro privacy you know
technologies and narratives are strong
there's a good really good book that I
recommend your listeners read called the
mandibles it's very very important and
it's a fiction book that describes 2028
2029 America where we basically default
on our debts and hyperinflation starts
to come to the United States it was
written maybe ten years ago and it talks
about all the different social impacts
that that mean that this starts to have
on people like that one of the
characters lives in Brooklyn there's a
refugee you know camp in Prospect Park
and people are fleeing there's all the
civil civil unrest etc etc etc but what
ends up happening throughout the book is
that you know your reliance on the
government becomes so severe in this
time of crisis that they end up
installing a chip in you and that's like
you know if you try to remove it without
the proper procedure it kills you and
it's obviously a dramatic narrative plot
device but it is something that is
something we should think about like you
know one it you've heard all kinds of
folks in the humanitarian sector
basically write things about how they
wish they could have chips for refugees
so that they could keep their digital
passport on it and we could know if
they've been vaccinated or whatever
I think this is a very dangerous road to
go down because I know how it ends
I mean I I know where the slippery slope
goes and the slippery slope ends in
xinjiang in northwestern China right now
where the government does have those
capabilities and they have all that
surveillance and control and power and
what is it result in the mass
incarceration of millions of ethnic
minorities if people the government
doesn't like that's where the sentence
there's no like good outcome
there is no utopian outcome here and I
think that you know another general
point to make here is that you know we
just don't
we just remember we don't need this to
fight the virus we don't have to go down
that road we can fight the virus in a in
a way that it does not require a police
state
you know remember not need a police
state to fight the virus we can fight
this thing in a decentralized way that
reflects our values again we can do all
these things that don't require civil
liberties intrusions whether it's
hand-washing masks testing social
distancing public investment in public
health infrastructure there's public
education that can be worked on all
sorts of things we can do that don't
require the stripping of our civil
liberties and Freedoms and that don't
require us to go down the path of a
country like China or a country like
Iran Iran is very similar to China they
also covered up the disease at the
beginning they also knew what how
dangerous kovat was yet told their
population that it was fine and the
population continued to go on these
religious pilgrimages and continue to
infect each other and even the state
airline kept flying flights to LAX
intima and to Italy into Europe etc and
the staff on the flights didn't know it
was dangerous and and Iran was largely
responsible for the spread of the virus
to Europe so at the beginning you had
these two dictatorships these do two
authoritarian systems in the Chinese
Communist Party in the Iranian mullahs
who were responsible for spreading most
of the disease to the world because of
censorship and lies and you know you
look at that model and how devastating
it's been for people who live in those
countries we don't want to go down that
road like let's go down the road of
whether it's Iceland or New Zealand or
Taiwan or I mean the argue believe in
California I mean I know it's been rough
here and we've had about a thousand
deaths but in a country of 42 million
we've done pretty well and we haven't
used mass surveillance I'm very proud of
that so far so even here we can do it in
the largest state in the United States
so I think we should follow you know our
values and try to fight the thing in a
way that won't have lasting implications
because we have to think about basically
this whole digital contact tracing thing
and emergency powers is the new Patriot
Act I mean you know right after 9/11 our
society was scared and
needed to shelter in an idea of unity
and in the strength of the government
and we gave them extraordinary powers
whether or not we did it specifically or
not we allowed them to take all kinds of
crazy powers over us that have led to a
dramatic erosion of civil liberties even
in America and the boogeyman then was
terrorism which was real and devastating
but you know did not excuse what
happened after similarly here kovat is
real and devastating but it does not
permit it does not excuse the government
to you know erode the values that we
built this nation on I think that is a
very folly thing so I think the idea
that we can fight the virus with
surveillance technology is is just a
really really bad idea
and you know one thing people say is
they're like look what do we have to
lose we're already being tracked on our
phones anyway who cares
you know I get a lot of this and I'm
like no you don't understand you know
though again just to repeat the way
you're you know you can currently be
tracked on your phone is what a lot less
accurate than Bluetooth beacon tracking
which is what this Apple Google thing
wants to do I mean remember folks this
can track you to the inch whereas the
current tracking can't and you know why
would you trade off even more of your
privacy and freedoms for something that
may not even work so I hope you can I
hope you can remember this as we as we
kind of move forward and think about a
way to have a decentralized response to
kovat I mean obviously we're seeing pomp
we're seeing a shift to the local to the
regional right everywhere in our
communities in our countries I mean the
u.s. is gonna pull its supply chains
back from China in other countries we're
gonna manufacture more internally it's
gonna change the world and and it's
gonna change us in a way that I think
the last two big crises we had didn't
really change our communities and my
advice to people as comes in three I've
said use encryption used something like
signal to communicate with your friends
and family let's double down on that be
kind to others and use Bitcoin and learn
about Bitcoin because I really believe
that bitcoin is such an elegant response
to the
two big threats that Americans are
facing the first threat I've gone over
in detail this threat of an
authoritarian overreach on our civil
liberties well guess what with with
Bitcoin we can have we have a system to
transact with one another that is
pseudonymous and can be very private and
doesn't need to leak or disclose
information about us to third parties
that is like one half of the genius of
satoshis vision and we can build a
financial and communications network
that again does not disclose our full
identity stack and that's like the most
exciting part of Bitcoin for me but on
the other hand bitcoin is also a
response to the way that money's
distributed and created right now
I mean it's buried in the Genesis block
right it is a critique of the bailout of
the banks in the last financial crisis
right so bitcoin kind of does two things
again it provides us a platform to build
pseudonymous more private sovereign
communications and and and financial
transactions and on the other hand it
removes the sort of Cantillon effect
possibility this effect named after this
British economist from the 19th century
who basically realized and described
that the people who were closer to the
money spigot to the money creation point
benefited more than the folks who
weren't right and we're seeing that on
full display right now right I mean
guess who got all their you know bailout
packages first right corporations not
not the people so bitcoin is a response
to that it's not gonna change corruption
or inequality or the fact that
governments issue debt to pay for things
that will always happen because we are
always going to live in societies at
least in near future where we have
governments but what it will change
hopefully as we move farther into the
future is this idea that like
bureaucrats who aren't even elected can
decide to create more money in an issue
and distribute it in a way that is built
on favoritism that is not possible with
Bitcoin it is an open market competition
it doesn't favor anybody over anyone
else and there can't be a manipulation
of the money supply in that way so
that's why I get
fired about that Bitcoin and why I think
you all should learn more about it and
understand it because it can it can
really help us on two fronts right now
that really threaten our our society and
I think one of the pieces I keep hearing
is like hey I'm sure that there's a bad
[ __ ] going on in Iran or China or
elsewhere in the world but out of the
united states right i live in a
democratic kind of free country and that
stuff doesn't happen here but what i
continue to try to explain to people and
i'd love to hear your opinion on is what
up this is happening here and in other
developed countries right so you know i
don't know if you saw the video that
floated around on twitter in australia
of a helicopter with night vision
literally finding three guys drinking
beers on a roof and using a microphone
to tell them to come down and they get
arrested or in kentucky yeah there's a
judge who's you know said to somebody
hey you won't stay in quarantine fine
we're literally gonna put AGP
gps-enabled ankle bracelet on right and
and we're gonna know where you are and
it just feels like yes it is bad in some
of these other places that we know are
authoritarian but it's also we're
starting to see signs of it being bad
here in the US or other developed
nations as well yeah i mean look i
haven't got you know when i was going
through all the different tools that our
governments disposals and society's
disposal before to tackle this thing i
didn't talk about lock down some
quarantine because i think that's the
part that even i'm unsure about I mean I
know that on some level they are
essential in some part in some way to
what extent is unclear but if the good
news isn't a democracy we should
arguably able to decide that meaning
like we should have a dialogue in the
open media in the press and in our local
jurisdictions and in our states and we
can have debates and our elected
representatives can decide whether or
not what what to do it has not been
perfect and there may be an overreaction
in many many ways with regard to this
restriction on our civil liberties and
freedom of movement and things like that
personally I think the way California is
doing is is is kind of perfect
as much as possible I mean it's as good
as it's gonna get maybe not I'll take
that back it's not perfect but it's as
good as it's gonna get in the Bay Area I
mean look I'm I'm free I can leave my
house I don't have a curfew
I go wherever I want get the card go
shopping I can support my local
businesses by online shopping I can I
can do what I want certain certain areas
are closed down to prevent people from
gathering like national parks parking
lots near national parks and the beecher
are closed down and maybe the city of
San Francisco has some like bizarre
decision making they've been making but
generally speaking I feel pretty free
here and if we can defeat the virus
without like unnecessary and positions
on our civil liberties and and and and
basically more surveillance then I'd be
very proud about that model and I hope
I'd hope others could learn from it but
there's no doubt that that we are seeing
some worrying things happening in the
United States I mean look this is the
greatest pandemic that we've seen in a
hundred years it's the biggest economic
contraction since the Great Depression
it's the greatest oil price decline on
record it's the greatest Central Bank
and government intervention in the
economy ever that we've seen so we're
entering into a land of unknowns no one
knows what's gonna happen that's the
crazy part you have all these
nobel-winning economists and people with
different backgrounds
nobody knows what's gonna happen we're
literally living in the in the land of
the unpredictable but I do think that
there's a balance we need to take where
we have to understand that the economic
implications of shutting down are gonna
be really bad and haunt us for many many
years and and will cause death and
suffering and on the other hand that we
do need to take the virus seriously the
the one thing that look Democratic
Society should take from this because
they should look again at Taiwan as an
example and Taiwan went through SARS and
they saw this and guess what they
planned for this they ran like tests and
they ran simulations and they knew this
was gonna come at some point this was
not a black swan right this is a white
swan right we knew this was going to
happen so for the federal government
United States to not have a plan and to
a point I don't know if you saw this but
apparently the HHS secretary appointed
somebody who ran a labradoodle company
to basically deal with America's
response to kovat in January and
February is inexcusable I mean we had
just gross and competence but the but
that's not necessary I mean we can do
better without changing the structure of
our government we just need different
people in charge but we can definitely
do better and we need to we need to plan
for these things if we have a plan in
place then there doesn't need to be any
restriction of our civil liberties right
so if the plan is in place and we have a
mutually agreed thing we're gonna do
when a pandemic hits there doesn't we
don't need to call in the army we don't
need to call in the National Guard we
don't need to have emergency
surveillance we have a plan that we've
worked on problem is we didn't have that
plan we're not we're not planning ahead
right now in the United States we're
planning for right now we were we're all
about January 2020 where the stock
markets at an all-time high and Tesla's
close to a thousand bucks a share or
whatever and we're just in the moment we
need to think about the long term and I
think we can and I think we can do that
through our democratic processes and we
need to and we shouldn't say no the
answer is actually to give the
government more power and to be more
like China I mean that's [ __ ] to be
honest like we do not want to be more
like the Chinese Communist Party again
anything you've ever heard about the way
they've reacted to the virus is full of
lies and nonsense and it's a giant
Potemkin village and the virus has
absolutely devastated their country has
killed untold people and is basically
ruined the image of Xi Jinping
internationally one thing I wanted to
say is that even just our trust in
centralized institutions again this
theme of a decentralized response where
we rely on each other in our communities
is very important if you look at the
World Health Organization it is
something that didn't shock me so I come
from the human rights background and I
know how corrupt
for example the UN Human Rights Council
is the UN Human Rights Council which is
supposed to kind of oversee Human Rights
around the world has China and Saudi
Arabia sitting on it right I mean it's
joke so I had already seen the World
Health Organization in the last ten
years given award to Robert Mugabe of
Zimbabwe who if anything was the sole
person who destroyed the health and
structure of Zimbabwe in a way that is
so sad and tragic I mean Zimbabwe
he put Zimbabwe back a hundred years
your listeners can read an amazing book
called the fear by Peter Godwin about
what what who got me didn't is in Bob
way and yet despite the fact that Mugabe
actually destroyed the public
infrastructure of this country the World
Health Organization tried to make him an
ambassador in like about less than ten
years ago
secondly the World Health Organization
went to North Korea three or four years
ago on a state-sponsored trip and
celebrated the Kim regime this is
literally the worst dictatorship in the
world that has some massive population
percentage of his population in gulags
and and yet they were celebrating them
so when you have to understand the guy
who's in charge of the World Health
Organization when he was a young guy he
worked for a Marxist Leninist party I
mean that's what he did when he was
younger
and when he was older he cut his teeth
working for Manabe Meles Zenawi who's
probably one of the most brutal
dictators in africa the guy killed
40,000 of his own people in one in one
sitting in 2005 so Ted Rose worked for
this guy and now he comes to the World
Health Organization of course he's gonna
favor the authoritarian model and he's
gonna you know basically side with with
the Chinese Communist Party and that's
why in December when there was evidence
from brave Chinese doctors who noticed
that there was a really worrying disease
that was spreading in Wuhan that's why
Beijing and the who didn't do anything
they instead censored the information
prevented people from learning about it
and then over the next three weeks the
what you know later on with the benefit
of hindsight what we've watched is we
watched seven million people leave Wuhan
between January December December 31 and
January 23 but there were no
restrictions at all so they infected the
world and they infected the rest of
China for their own self-serving agenda
I mean the Xi Jinping had this big event
that he was planning from the 14th to
the 17th and he really wanted it to
happen in Wuhan
so they basically just censored all the
news and didn't count any cases until
after that was over and then the damage
had been done and the World Health
Organization has been complicit the
entire time basically parroting China's
talking points saying it's not nothing
to worry about saying there's not
there's no human to human transition the
transmission the World Health
Organization was saying that as of
January 17th when the Chinese
authorities knew that this thing was
viral the Taiwanese authorities knew
that this was viral but because the
World Health Organization doesn't
consider Taiwan a country they did
Taiwan is not allowed to join the World
Health Organization because it's
basically owned by the Chinese Communist
Party and they were like again parroting
all their talking points the world
didn't know any better and yes like you
know did the American government react
and competently very much so and it's
very frustrating and unforgivable but
when it comes to like American society
in the media and a lot of policymakers
how are we supposed to know like the
Chinese government and the WHO and the
who were saying that it was under
control and there's a video from late
January of Tadros on stage with Xi
Jinping where he's praising the Chinese
leaders handling of the virus I mean
it's actually so crazy Orwellian and
then you saw this continue to proceed
where the who at first was saying that
it was racist to stop travel from China
at the end of January and and then they
were condemning essentially the US
government others who were trying to
stop travel from China meanwhile at the
end of March
once China decided it was time to shut
down their own travel and only permit
one flight per day from each major
carrier the who didn't have a criticism
for that so they're totally in China's
pocket they've been distributing
misinformation about masks missing I
mean they were telling people you
shouldn't wear one unless you're sick
until March they were distributing this
information about the way the virus
moves the way it's transmitted this is
not an institution to be trusted and
it's emblematic of a lot of our
institutions right now these alphabet
soup organizations that you know aren't
accountable to the public and we
shouldn't trust them
I mean look even our own CDC was
distributing misinformation
obviously the white house was too so in
America we need to think for ourselves
and think critically and you know we
need to double down on our own powers of
Investigation and truth seeking and
sense making and build our own
communities and question everything
basically is is quite important both on
the health side the political side and
on the economic side and I do think that
there's something about again to go back
to Bitcoin I think there's something
about it that I don't know helps you
fashion world view that is both on the
one hand optimistic but on the other
hand very you know very skeptical of
what people say because essentially what
you have now is um the world coalescing
around modern monetary theory and
basically saying that the government
should just print more money without
having any tax revenue and that you can
run a massive deficit and it's fine and
you know maybe they're right for the for
the time being maybe we can do that
right and maybe there won't be inflation
or shortages but you know mmt basically
dictates that politicians be able to
just decide how much money there should
exist and they should only stop printing
money when when we see inflation and
shortages that's literally like what it
what it says if you read the texts of
the MMT folks and you know what like at
least Bitcoin gives us an option to not
participate in that if we don't want I
think that government policy is trending
towards mmt in most countries I mean
this is kind of the future of government
money it's going to be much more easy
money it's gonna be you know much more
in supply for potentially the you know a
decreasing amount of goods and services
so we'll see how that ends up but the
point is that Bitcoin gives us kind of a
parallel thing where we can opt into a
different financial system and the fact
that the mainstream media and the world
is still ignorant about Bitcoin is
something that lines up with my
observation that they're also ignorant
about the World Health
and a huge battery of other things like
you just got to think for yourself you
know yeah and I guess part of the thing
that I sit and I scares me the most is
even if the people have distrust for
those large organizations like the WHO
the CDC whoever it is we're seeing other
companies use them as the standard right
so we just saw YouTube for example said
they're gonna take down any Content that
was crazy contradicts the WHO and I was
sitting there and I think that the CEO
literally said into the video if you
tell people to consume vitamin C right
that is scientifically proven right
we're in a sense of that and I I mean I
get it but like she literally goes on to
say let her quote is literally that
anything that goes against the World
Health Organization's recommendations
will be a violation of our policies and
again folks the World Health
Organization denies that Taiwan's a
country helped China the Chinese
companies party cover up the outbreak
and spread this thing to your
communities and ruined your your lives
you know celebrates dictators around the
world and spreads misinformation how can
we put YouTube possibly use them as the
arbiter of what is truth but that's the
situation we're in now so yeah be
skeptical yeah and I think part of it
was just that means that anyone who is
saying we're masks
three weeks ago four weeks ago would
have technically been in violation of
the policies but now they're being
mandated by US government right in
various local state or in some cases you
know those governments and so to me it
just feels like we're getting into this
very slippery slope where you can hide
behind policies and it's not just
YouTube it's every major platform that
deals yeah I'm a Content moderation but
at what point do you reach this line of
it is just straight censorship versus
you're actually trying to prevent the
spread of fake news and protect people
yeah well I'm unless I mean to me
censorship is about the state it's about
the state saying this particular speech
will not be permitted if private
companies wanna
sensor certain things I do that is
problematic but it's not the same thing
I mean what I'm what I'm on guard for is
actual state censorship again private
companies they kind of do their own
thing there is a good argument that
private companies are essentially
becoming public infrastructure at this
point and maybe we need to rethink that
but generally speaking I I don't let's
just put it this way I don't have a
problem getting good information right
now like yes you have to navigate
through a lot of nonsense but like you
can be more well educated today than any
human in the history of humanity like it
I don't I think this whole idea that
like the platforming and like you know
corporate censorship on our social media
platforms is is is a huge and dire
threat is a little much like I don't
know I can still get opinions of anybody
I want somehow on one one way or another
I'm not like prevented you know the
government is not preventing me from
accessing opinions for particular person
I do view what's happening with YouTube
very it's very concerning but it seems
inevitable I mean who else are they
gonna I mean who you know who else is
going to be their source of truth I mean
it's supposed to be the world how I mean
this is what how broken the world is the
world health organization is supposed to
be that arbiter of truth is the the UN
Human Rights Council is supposed to be
the last word on human rights right the
Federal Reserve is supposed to be the
world's and the IMF are supposed to be
the lenders of last resort and all of
these organizations are doing things
that are very controversial at best and
in some cases are you know outright
disastrous so what are we supposed to
rely on so again I think this is why
you're gonna see this shift towards
whether it's the family the community
localism regionalism we're starting to
live it man I mean it's it's happening
and in that context I think we can
internally and in our own communities
again rely on on things like encryption
and protect our privacy and protect our
rights I think that the idea of what is
desirable
for even Americans it's gonna very much
change in the next few years like the
idea of wanting an apartment downtown
may may not be you know what everybody
wants anymore you know and I know that
it was only a subset of the population
that wanted that but even for those
folks they may want to get a little
space you know so we're gonna see
dramatic dramatic shifts and hopefully
we can we can we can we can see some
good out of this but I don't know I mean
like for you like what would it take for
you to feel comfortable going to a
concert right now like what would it
take for you to feel comfortable just
going right now what would have to be
the reality I'm probably the wrong
person to ask this question mainly
because I generally am of the belief
that if you are concerned about your
health
uh-huh you alternately have the personal
responsibility to take care of yourself
right so so what I mean by that first is
if you are old if you are sick even for
existing conditions and you understand
that you have a higher propensity for
being infected and ultimately
potentially dying you should take every
precaution possible not to get sick so
wear masks wash your hands you know do
whatever you need to do don't go outside
you know don't come in contact with
people all of those things are kind of
first ultimately a personal
responsibility of course when it comes
to somebody like me who you know is very
fortunate to be younger to not have any
of the pre-existing conditions high to
kind of be at a lower level maybe not of
getting infected but definitely of
having kind of the death rate effect
marry fact that that it comes down to
generally being able to balance the
safety of you and those around you with
the other aspects of life right and so
what I mean by that is wearing a mask
like I'd be happy to go places and if we
had to wear masks if that helped me be
safer and those around me right to go to
something like a concert again if you're
saying hey let's go sit in mosh pit
right and kind of be alright
where everything is you know we're
literally people are coughing on you and
stuff like that that's one thing versus
to go and actually sit in a theater
right or some sort of much more ability
I guess what I'm getting at is um there
are a lot of things that we used to do
that we're not going to do anymore or at
least for awhile and we're struggling
with that a demon rights foundation
because look we do live events we bring
people together and then they may not be
able to happen for a while we got to do
a lot of things virtually but if you
think about like if your parents and you
want to when you're gonna feel so
comfortable send your kid back to school
if you like eating out at restaurants
like when eventually we do get back to
that are you gonna expect the waiters to
wear masks and gloves and for the chef's
to be a temperature checked is is that a
reasonable expectation I mean what the
only society that's that that seems to
be like promoting its I were back to
normal I'm in an aggressive way is China
and they're like you know probably more
similar to London or New York or one of
these big metropolitan areas that got
hit really hard they're like coming
they're trying to come back online right
again their clique color-coding citizens
and doing all these different
extraordinary measures I don't think we
need to do that again as I've underlined
but I think it's going to be quite the
process for us as a society it what is
inspiring is that there are some
societies Democratic ones that handled
it the right way that we're careful and
that art a lot more normal I mean if you
actually look at Taiwan they're playing
baseball man I mean there's no you know
there's no one in the crowd the crowd
but they're playing you know so I'm
hopeful that like we can get sports back
we can get music back but I think it's
just gonna be this process and when you
know I think people need to understand
that that's gonna have a very long tail
economic effect on our lives I mean we
just saw this data point today another
four plus million people are unemployed
I mean we've got probably close to 30
million now I mean the the st. Louis Fed
was projecting that by June that be
fifty to sixty million unemployed a 30
percent unemployment rate in our country
so I mean that's that's really sad here
but that that may happen
I mean look and we're in advanced
country with a lot of infrastructure I
mean think about if you know some of the
countries I'm I'm kind of I'm talking to
people working in certain countries I
mean I mean Kenya has fewer ventilators
than London you know and as a much
larger population a lot of countries
don't have the infrastructure we have no
clue like whether or not Cove is having
a big impact I mean Indonesia will the
world's largest democracy just declared
today that they're shutting down all the
flights so a lot of these other
countries you know that were spared the
initial impact of this thing are now
just starting to really feel it right so
if you look at sub-saharan Africa Latin
America Southeast Asia the Middle East I
mean they're getting hit the Saudi royal
family has a huge outbreak inside the
royal family Latin America has mass
number of cases and again when these
numbers spread we get a reaction from
these governments so there are like
unfortunately like two dozen governments
in sub-saharan Africa that have declared
all kinds of emergency measures to fight
the virus right so I take the virus very
seriously but I'm very concerned about
the longer tail economic and political
consequences and I think we need to act
right now to challenge this idea that
like an authoritarian response a
response of surveillance and of giving
up our data and of trusting the
government to do the right thing I don't
that is just clearly not the right
answer I mean whether you live in
America or for in China like your
government has betrayed you right in a
certain amount in a certain way right
and I just think we need to take things
into our own hands a little bit and you
know be be as you were saying the
sovereign and be responsible and that
has just never been more clear to me
than it is today but it does give me
great hope and an optimism that you know
we do still have ways to communicate
with each other privately we do have an
alternative financial system that again
is not is not controlled by bureaucrats
and we do have you know our families and
communities that that we can we can work
with and build and build from and I
think a lot of people probably are are
feeling that right now but again like
don't fall into this trap of thinking
that Apple and Google are gonna save us
with this digital contact tracing
nonsense I mean literally I was I was
thinking about this the other day there
there there again like you're talking
about two of the world's largest
corporations are unrolling a new
surveillance system to track potentially
3.5 billion people how does that not go
wrong like how is that not the opening
scene of a dystopic science fiction
thriller I mean come on guys
like this is absolutely ridiculous don't
fall into that trap learn more about it
and be careful you know don't worship
these companies for trying to do
something that on its face like doesn't
even work and it's just gonna have such
a bad legacy on our on our civil
liberties and privacy let's let's not go
through the the Patriot Act again I mean
we're still dealing with that man there
was still a story the other day you know
the government is spending hundreds of
millions of dollars on this crazy
surveillance and they're not it's not
leading to any arrests like it's just
it's just bureaucratic waste on top
ineffective bureaucratic waste on top of
the fact that it has destroyed privacy
and and has given the government new
powers that didn't need so as much as I
hate to say it I mean I Cove it is gonna
be a sea-change moment just like the
9/11 was for for for civil liberties and
privacy however the good news is we now
have more tools at our disposal than we
did back then I mean people can you
there was no signal back then
I mean people didn't have a way to
communicate with anyone else in the
world in a way that was pretty much
assured to be private now we do Bitcoin
didn't exist not only does it exist now
but it's it's very usable by whether
it's nonprofits organizations people you
know we can send any amount of money we
want anyone else in the world in a
matter of minutes and no one can stop it
like we have new tools and technologies
she said that we didn't have back then
but we have to rely on them we have to
educate each other and communicate about
the potential of them more often than
than we are doing right now I think
that's a fantastic point to finish up
where where can people go find you on on
the Internet and also go learn more
about the human rights foundation work
yeah so the human rights foundation
again a nonprofit that focuses on
helping people around the world we live
under authoritarian societies the four
billion that don't have the rights and
freedoms we do you can find us at hrs
org or on twitter at h RF you can find
me on twitter at Gladstein GL ad st e n
i'll be speaking in a bunch of
conferences virtually in the next in in
the next few months and you can also
check out a book i co-wrote last year
with a bunch of other folks in the
Bitcoin space called a little bit coin
book it's on Amazon and it's our take on
trying to explain why money is broken
today and why why satoshis invention was
so important and it does it in a plain
speak way you don't have to have a
particular political opinion or a
particular knowledge about economics or
technology to read the book in a in a
couple hours it's very easy reading and
it's now in a bunch of different
languages and something I'm certainly
proud of and hope it can be useful for
folks awesome listen I really appreciate
taking the time to do this you guys are
doing incredible work over there and I
think that you know people just need to
stay vigilant you guys leading the
charge so just from everyone else thank
you for for all the work you're doing
and watch this again
absolutely thanks for having me I'm very
grateful